okay so with my academia and black
clover both entering their final arcs
it's no surprise that the authors have
been trying to wrap up several lingering
plot lines for example in the past 18
months of my hero we've witnessed
dabby's backstory deco unlocking nearly
all of his quirks and most recently the
reveal of the ua traitor this is a
storyline that was set into motion so
long ago that after a while there were
people online who genuinely believed the
harakos had forgotten about it with that
much time to plan things out you'd
expect the eventual traitor revealed to
be an iconic moment for the series on
par with other famous events but
unfortunately that's not what ended up
happening instead what we got was an
okay reveal that was lacking in a few
different ways and for me personally i
didn't realize just how underwhelming it
was until black clover recently swooped
in with a traitor reveal of its own in
this video i'll be explaining why as a
fan of both series black clover did
everything right when it came to
exposing who the traitor is while on
this occasion my hero didn't have the
same impact
before we get into it don't forget to
hit that sub button for more anime and
manga content like this and as the video
continues feel free to let me know
whether you agree or disagree in the
comments down below
okay so for those of you watching who
have no idea what happened in either
series i'm gonna do a very quick recap
but obviously there will be massive
spoilers ahead in my here academia the
uh traitor was revealed to be aoyama
after his parents were caught loudly
talking about it in the forest if they'd
been whispering instead then it's
possible they never would have been
found out but in this case higgakurei
overheard their conversation soon
afterwards the family were arrested but
within just two chapters it was decided
that aoyama wouldn't be expelled and his
classmates had all chosen to forgive him
the reason for this was that although he
betrayed them he only did these things
because all for one was threatening his
family by contrast to this in black
clover the trait was revealed to be the
wizard king julius who turned out to be
the mastermind behind the dark triad the
dark triad have essentially been the
main villains of this manga for the last
couple years but in reality julius is
their older brother and his real name is
lucia segratus this twist was easily one
of the most surprising moments of the
entire series and it was so well
executed that even though i predicted it
might happen six months earlier the
reveal still caught me completely off
guard in order to explain why that is
we're about to examine the four key
elements that make an effective trait to
reveal in my opinion the first of those
elements being trust it sounds obvious
to say this but the more we trust a
character and believe they're a good
person the more shocking it is if they
turn out to not be who we think this is
because trustworthy characters have
repeatedly done things said things and
thought things that have convinced us of
who they are so much so that it's hard
to imagine they could be anything else
purely as an example todoroki and yuno
are two characters who have earned the
complete trust of the audience to the
point where even if there was a hint
that they might secretly be evil most
people wouldn't take it seriously
instead what we'd likely do is wait for
there to be more concrete evidence since
either of them being traitors wouldn't
fit in with everything we know
this same logic applies to julius
because although there were a few sus
things about him that we'll be talking
about later for the most part he had
earned our trust
thanks to his internal monologues he'd
proven consistently that his main goal
was to end discrimination in the clover
kingdom and to achieve that mission he
often showed kindness to people who were
outcast by society whereas most nobles
only cared about their own social class
and their own wealth julius was the one
who had faith in the potential of all
humans regardless of whether they
happened to be a peasant as wizard king
he then took steps that led to his dream
becoming more of a reality and when it
came down to it he was willing to die to
ensure the progress they made wasn't
lost
everything considered the wizard king is
a character who gained the trust of the
audience and judging from chat to 331
julius himself didn't know he was the
traitor
rather his character seems to be a porn
of lucius in a comparable way to how
aoyama is appointable for one but the
key difference here is that julius is
someone we trusted
when it comes to aoyama for the first
300 chapters we rarely ever heard what
he was thinking and his behavior was
easily the most suspected class 1a if
you would ask any myhera fan who among
classes was most likely to be the
traitor the usual answer was either him
or invisible girl because we didn't know
anything about them and they gave us no
real reason to trust them aoyama in
particular was described by deku as a
loner who doesn't go out of his way to
make friends and unlike the main
characters his motivations in life were
also unclear in spite of being on the
hero course his conviction was lacking
compared to the other kids partly
demonstrated by how easily he was
prepared to give up during the hero
license exam
of course that's not to say that he's
not been heroic at all because more
often than not he does eventually do the
right thing but the point i'm making is
that until recently we never saw inside
his head and therefore never knew what
was driving him this is a large factor
in why it was so easy to believe that he
could be the traitor and so when it
turned out to be him the only surprising
thing about it was that it wasn't
hagakurei for that reason black clover
wins when it comes to building trust
which ultimately made this moment a lot
more exciting
now moving on for a traitor revealed to
be truly mind-blowing it can't be too
predictable but at the same time it also
can't just come out of nowhere with
nothing to back it up that's why an
effective reveal benefits from setup
which in this context means small clues
throughout the story that subtly
indicate who a person really is
in my opinion neither series did a bad
job of this although my hero loses out
again because there were times when the
hints just became way too obvious
examples of this include the usg attack
where ayama went missing the entire time
and then breaks the fourth wall to tell
us his location was a secret on top of
that there was the episode when he was
acting super weird towards deku and the
narration even said that this was when
ayama began showing his true self stuff
like this contributed to why the reveal
felt so unsurprising but that doesn't
mean there weren't other hints that were
more subtle for instance his
incompatibility with his quirk was a
running theme since he was first
introduced and it was comparable to how
midoriya himself was struggling with one
for all this parallel was clever
foreshadowing of how they both received
the power derived from all for one and
it's one of the many clues that prove
herokuchi planned for him to be the
traitor from the beginning a different
hint that only made sense after the
reveal happened was aoyama's reaction to
all might fighting afo although we
didn't know it the reason they were
emotional was because they thought this
might be their chance to finally be free
of off one's influence in that sense the
setup for his reveal was mostly good
like i said but certain aspects were way
too obvious which contributed to its
predictability compared to this black
clover handled things more discreetly
with the setup consisting only of small
things that didn't cause too much
suspicion by themselves starting from
the beginning the first time we properly
meet julius is in chapter 10 when he was
sneaking around the clover kingdom
looking for new types of magic in this
moment he takes a strong fascination
with asta's abilities and in hindsight
this was our first clue as we now know
lucius needed three things for his plan
to succeed number one was someone with
dark magic number two was someone with
world tree magic and number three was
someone with the power to defeat
lucifero having already acquired yarmy
and william astor was the final piece of
the puzzle hence how lucius was so sure
that things would be going his way
the next hint came when their main
characters met the wizard king as he was
able to recognize the devil language in
astu's gramoire based on what we know of
lucius everything points to him being
the most talented person when it comes
to devil possession and later in the
series julius is shown to share at least
some of that extensive devil knowledge
despite that though in this scene he
pretends to not know anything about it
and looking back now that is incredibly
suspicious
another clue that makes more sense in
the present day is julius's actions in
the fight against party during that
fight the wizard king refused to use any
lethal force since killing parchee would
have also meant that william would be
killed as well at the time he believed
this was because he cared about william
and to an extent that might still be
true however we can't deny that lucius
had an influence since he needed
williams magic to open the gate to the
underworld
without world tree magic lucius's entire
plan would have fallen apart so the
wizard king's reluctance to kill vandals
now has a whole new context
anyhow there were a bunch of other small
hints exactly like the ones i've just
mentioned including how the shadow
palace has the same symbol as the one in
lucius's head in that way there was a
ton of setup for julius being the
traitor but nothing so obvious that
you'd be certain it would happen
switching over to the execution this
element is all about how the reveal
actually went down for mario academia
everything begins with all for one in
chapter 335 afo was bragging about how
he has multiple ways to achieve a single
ambition and during this speech he was
confirmed that he has a mole inside ua
harakoshi ended that chapter by heavily
implying that the mall was invisible
girl mainly because he knew we'd believe
it for the reasons i mentioned earlier
that being said in the next chapter the
traitor was confirmed to be the other
most suspicious classmate and in terms
of execution there was a big problem
given that this storyline was set up so
many years ago it was disappointing for
the trailer only to be exposed because
the ariamas were too clueless to use
their inside voices to me it felt like
hurricane was looking for a way to
swiftly wrap up this plot thread and
yuga's parents accidentally revealing
everything to hagakure well that was a
quick way of doing that
in the end it just seemed way too
convenient which is a shame because i
did actually like the backstory about
how aliama received the quirk from afo
in the case of black clover's execution
the betrayal happens in chapter 331
with a concerned looking damnatio
walking through the royal capital at
this time we had no idea what was about
to come because up until this point no
one had even mentioned the idea of there
being a traitor the scene then switches
over to the wizard king who's receiving
an update about how asta and the magic
knights have defeated the dark triad
julius then responds to this news with
genuine relief and it's clear from his
inner monologue that he is on the side
of the clover kingdom however he then
goes on to think that something doesn't
feel quite right and this is when
damnatio enters the room
over the next couple pages damnatio
explains that he's been researching the
existence of devils and according to the
records a devil known as asteroth
vanished from the underworld more than
20 years ago asteroth was one of the
three most powerful devils in existence
and just like julius his magic attribute
was time magic
as this info is being revealed we hear
damnatio's in a monologue in which he
desperately hopes there's no connection
between the supreme devil and the wizard
king as the page then turns julius comes
to the realization that he is asteroth
and his expression indicates that he's
only just now understanding what he
really is i thought this moment was
especially interesting because in the
past he has mentioned how he always used
to ask himself this question
over the following seconds he
frantically gives damnatio a warning but
is interrupted as his body
uncontrollably starts to transform then
for the first time ever his previously
coverless grimoire generates a cover out
of nowhere revealing that the clover
kingdom's wizard king has actually been
from the spay kingdom this entire time
that info by itself would have been a
cliffhanger worthy of ending any chapter
but as things continue we get the
additional reveal that julius is now a
completely different person
overall the execution of this was well
written with tabata starting off by
luring us into a false sense of security
as he reinforced the idea that julius is
on the right side this loyalty is then
reluctantly brought into question by
damnatio but before we have any time to
form a real conclusion the wizard king
himself straight up confirms that he's a
devil what follows this is three pages
of unexpected hype that any black clover
fan would appreciate and by the end of
it it seems like everything happened
exactly the way lucius intended
finally this brings us to the fourth
element of a good trait to reveal which
is the impact it has on other characters
and the world itself
as the wizard king julius being a devil
host has huge political ramifications
hence why this final arc is called the
ultimate wizard king what this title
suggests is that when all is said and
done someone will need to replace him in
that position and depending on who the
next person is it could permanently
change the social dynamics of the
kingdom furthermore lucius's grand plan
to remake humanity will affect thousands
if not millions of people so his reveal
does have a significant impact on
virtually everyone
now moving down to a more personal level
as i'm making this video black clover is
currently on hiatus so we don't yet know
how characters like yarmy and william
will react with julius being their
mentor they're understandably going to
be devastated to find out who he really
is while astor and yuna will also likely
find it hard to accept however right now
that is just speculation until the
series comes back so all we can be sure
of is that lucius will have a huge
impact on the world because he pretty
much said it but in terms of the
individual impact we just can't know
when it comes to my cure academia
aliama's betrayal has already had
different kinds of impacts one of which
is the impact on class 1a up till now
they've been put through all sorts of
hell because of the traitor including
froppy being an inch away from death
bakago being kidnapped by the villains
all might losing one for all and deku
genuinely thinking he was about to die
against muscular these were some of the
most traumatic moments of their lives
caused by aoyama's actions so it was a
bit jarring that everyone was ready to
move on so quickly without any
significant debate for a bit of context
alyama was arrested halfway through
chapter 337 and before we even got to
halfway through the next chapter the
students had decided to move on
if there had been a longer more
meaningful discussion between the class
then i think forgiving him would have
been fine but the way it happened made
it seem like the impact of his betrayal
wasn't really a big factor
that being said on the other side
something that was done better was the
impact the ioma's reveal had on the
villains by his secret being exposed it
gave the heroes a chance to form a new
plan to take down all for one with yuga
being used as debate to lure him out
luckily this plan did actually end up
working and seemingly for the first time
ever afo himself had actually been
tricked based on that the traitor
storyline will have a big impact on how
the final arc plays out and even though
aoyama might not face harsh consequences
from the heroes recent chapters make it
seem like he might face retribution from
the villains overall with black clover
being on hiatus it's not fair for me to
say which of these reveals will have the
longer term impact but based on the
positives and negatives that we've just
heard about mha let me know in the
comments how you think black clover will
do by comparison
before we end the video one side note i
wanted to mention is that harukoshi
recently confirmed that his original
plan was to expose aoyama during the
forest training camp although we'll
likely never know how the original
reveal was supposed to happen at the
very least it wouldn't have involved
ayama's parents just blurting it out
which is good enough
anyway don't forget to sub to the
channel if you haven't already and as
always drop a like if you like the video
until the next one peace out